- DeAngelis rhymes with Los Angeles,
is what Meg just told me.
- We were just discussing that, so.
- Hey, guys! I'm here with Meg DeAngelis.
- Hey, what's up? Woot woot.
- We're about to record an entire episode
of Not Too Deep, which
after you watch this video
you should go over to SoundCloud or iTunes
and listen to that full episode.
But before we do that, we are doing this.
And this is what we are calling
the blindfolded gingerbread
house challenge.
Said with such confidence.
(laughing)
- The blindfolded gingerbread
house making contest.
- Yes! Something like that.
You've seen the title.
Meg and I will be
blindfolded for five minutes,
and we will try to make
the best gingerbread
houses that we can.
How do you feel?
- I'm ready. Now I just wanna get into it.
- She told me she's very competitive.
I also feel like you have the advantage
because you're a very skilled crafter.
And so I feel like art
comes naturally to you,
whereas for me, it's always
shoehorned into my life.
Jack Ferry has the timer.
- [Voiceover] Yes, I do.
- So five minutes is what we'll have.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- And then at the end, you guys,
as well everyone here on Not Too Deep,
will judge what, their favorite house.
Okay, you ready?
- Yeah. We have to be more optimistic.
- Let's be optimistic about this.
This will not suck completely.
- It won't suck completely,
'cause we'll get to eat it afterwards.
- That's true too.
(dramatic music)
[Voiceover] - Blindfolds on.
- Blindfolds on.
Right, that's part of this.
- Oh, it matches my shirt.
- Does it? Aw, no points for matching.
You can't sway them.
Instantly forget where
everything is around me.
Okay, I, that's me, that's me.
Ugh, I'm already very stressed out. Yay.
[Voiceover] - On your
mark, get set, gingerbread!
- Gingerbread!
- Okay. Graham crackers, graham crackers.
- Okay, okay.
- Walls, ceiling.
- Oh, no.
This is hard to do when
you're not blindfolded.
Why did we make it a blind,
aaaagh!
Touching icing!
And I can't tell if it's coming out.
- I don't know if I'm spreading the table.
(laughter)
- I'm just, I'm touching a lot of icing.
Oh, no, okay.
Let's, you know what, sometimes
when you can't do art, it's best to just
do a lot of bad art, instead
of a little bit of good art.
Ok, where did that go? Okay.
- Science.
- Okay, maybe it'll help
if we sing Christmas songs.
- If we sing Christmas songs?
That'll make it better.
- Deck the halls with -
- With -
- I actually only know the version
where the school burns down.
You know the one that
everyone used to think -
- What? (laughter)
- No, I'm not crazy.
- Where did, you went to school in Canada?
- Yeah.
Is that what they sing there?
- Just for fun,
but I don't know the real version.
That's the problem from that.
- Oh no. Oh, yeah.
I don't know that version at all.
But that sounds fun.
I'm making nothing but great calls,
I feel like, over here.
- Where are my walls?
- [Voiceover] Ok, we're 90 seconds in.
- We're a minute and a half in?
- I'm just holding two pieces of cracker.
(laughing)
That's literally where I'm
at right now, guys. Okay.
- We can do this. We can do this.
You know, art is in the
eye of the beholder.
Is this on the table?
Oh, I have the, what's this thing?
- I found something.
Okay, I got this. I got this.
- Oh!
- I'm going to use the
marshmallows as snow.
You know what, it's gonna,
I'm gonna go card-house style.
- Okay.
- Mm, I feel like this is very, very good.
I don't even know where they are now.
- I have no, I'm touching,
oh, that felt like a marshmallow.
and a wrong place for a marshmallow.
There's some.
- [Voiceover] Two and a half minutes left.
- Two and a half. We're halfway through.
- Oh, I dropped all my walls. (laughter)
Ok, what is this? What are you?
- Let's see.
- Um, okay. I honestly
have no idea what this is.
Oh. Sprinkles.
- Yep,nope. That doesn't
squirt out that way. (laughter)
This comes this way. That's right.
- I don't know what I'm doing.
- I feel like mine's really good.
Uh oh. Oh, what's that?
This is a thing that I
didn't think was here.
- Okay.
- Where's, oh, yes.
That looks good.
How much time we got left?
- [Voiceover] A minute and a half left.
- A minute and a half left?
Well, pin a rose on our nose.
(laughter)
Something fell into my lap. (laughter)
Oh, no. Stop sabotaging mine!
- Oh. Oh!
- Ok, there we go.
This feels good and right.
How do I make a flag? (laughter)
Maybe a little bit of this.
Ok. Oh. (laughter)
This is, if you've ever wondered what
- [Voiceover] Ten seconds.
- art looks like.
Ten seconds?
- [Voiceover] And, time.
- Time! Hands up.
Oh gosh.
- Okay, go.
- Oh, we went for a very
similar aesthetic. (laughing)
This was a hard one to judge, you guys.
- Oh, that looks really cool.
- Yeah, there was, you know, you can see
the evolution of
destruction that happened.
But there was an attempt to make
an actual gingerbread house,
in the very beginning.
- And that's what matters.
- It's impossible to
judge, but we're gonna
leave it up to you guys in the comments
to let us know whose gingerbread mansion
looks better. (laughing)
And if you haven't already,
go to iTunes or SoundCloud
and listen to the full
episode of Not Too Deep
with Meg.
Meg, where can they find
you on social media?
I should've waited till after
you ate the marshmallow. (laughter)
- It's okay.
You can go to YouTube.com/maybaby.
- And do it, her DIY videos,
this only gives you a taste of it.
I've learned how to make shirts from you.
- Really?
- It was,
yeah, it's really really great.
So I highly recommend.
Also the color scheme
in the videos, gorgeous.
- I only use three
colors, I'm really weird.
- I'm into it. Who needs
more than three colors?
We got green, brown, white, red.
I don't know.
So you went to school in Germany, then?
- I did. I went to an
international school.
So people are from everywhere.
- Oh, whoah.
- Yeah.
- So it's like Hogwarts?
- Oh, I wish. I wish so much. (laughter)